[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils ont ça fait longtemps que travailler
ici vous ça fait sept ans un ordi ce
pourquoi ils leur disent avoir millions
je suis arrivé j'avais nordiste davance
haye vouliez faire bonne impression
non mais avait comme du métro à vous
êtes venu en taxi dont à pied et à pied
est arrivé avec une heure d'avancé suite
à 50 mètres va vous amener ou en métro
parce que c'est direct ah oui alors ça
fait sept ans que vous connaissez le
patron pierre marcelle allons avancer
pas monsieur garcès messieurs vladimira
s'était pas monsieur marseillan c'est
monsieur vladimir stepanov a annoncé à
l'été monsieur marcel javaux j'aurais
pas pour nous cela dit mais c'était un
parent monsieur marcel beau père
monsieur marcel assez le beau père a
mais c'est le contraire monsieur marcel
c'est le beau père est alors c'est lui
qui a ouvert la boîte aux homos c'est
toute une histoire
figurez-vous je me figure un soir
monsieur vladimir vos folies bergère oui
il en sort ébloui par les plumes quelle
pub et fument des danseuses des folies
bergères harry alors alors il a acheté
une vingtaine d'autres ruches et
instructeur avec matin pourquoi faire
les réveille matin bas pour donner à
manger aux autruches avec l'aco bref
bref il a vendu ses plumes aux folies
bergères il a fait fortune l'acheter ce
cabaret mais dit monsieur marcel à lille
et lé métier aussi
ah non pas du tout il était faible en
tirages nisr ferblantier argenis us
airways et dépenses fournis avec des
vieilles casseroles
mais comment at il rencontré la fille à
monsieur vladimir alors là c'est une
merveilleuse histoire d'avant
figurez-vous je figure marceline la
fille de monsieur vladimir avait des
taches de sang mêlé taches de sang ouais
des taches de rousseur à des tâches de
son oui c'est ça la solidarité elle
avait pris le soleil à travers une
passoire exact hier c'est ce qu'est la
cour du mariage à lyon dont messi parce
que marceline était désolé de ses tâches
et monsieur marcel a trouvé le moyen de
les faire disparaître dans les efface en
tenons on en rajoute en dot à sa joie
pas c'est pas ça
monsieur marcel a pris une passoire il a
posé son visage de marceline en plein
soleil
mais comment at il fait pour ajouter des
tâches en déplaçant les trous de la
passoire
[Musique]